à l'époque je démarrais à peine mon
entreprise et je venais d'avoir une
rupture sentimentale on n'y avait plus
grand chose qui me retenait en france et
j'avais envie d'un nouveau départ il y a
deux ans anne donguy s'imaginer tout
quitter en france pour s'installer au
canada
elle tombe sur un site internet
it's canada time.com qui fait la
promotion d'une immigration au canada à
moi j'ai cru vraiment que c'était le 6
du canada j'ai cru que c'était le site
officiel yp canada times propose alors à
1 2 ghz qu'ils appellent un forfait vip
ce forfait comprend à la fois un visa un
billet d'avion un travail un logement
le tout pour la modique somme de 7000
euros c'est environ 10 mille dollars
ça correspondait à mon rêve il me disait
même que le canada recherchait des gens
qui voulait entreprendre comme moi des
entrepreneurs donc je correspondait
exactement à ce que le canada vous
voulez mais après des mois d'attentes
rien ne se passe it's canada times comme
d'autres sites similaires dit travailler
avec de véritables consultants en
immigration reconnue par le gouvernement
du canada
anne tanguy contacte alors directement
celui qui serait chargé de son dossier
mais celui ci nie alors collaboré avec
cette entreprise
le sang mais monte à la tête et j'ai
compris anne tanguy n'est pas la seule à
se dire victime de ce type de site
nous avons recueilli le témoignage d'une
quinzaine de personnes qui racontent des
histoires similaires des conseillers en
immigration se plaignent également
d'avoir vu leur identité d'être usurpée
des clients potentiels qui ont payé
l'argent malheureusement les personnes
qui ont été fraudées nous ont appelés
pour savoir si ou le statut de leur
dossier
et à ce moment là on a remarqué que ces
gens là ne font pas partie de la base de
données de notre clientèle
notre nom était juste utiliser l'agencé
des services frontaliers a reçu cinq
cent quarante plaintes sur ce sujet
depuis l'an passé le centre antifraude
du canada fait état quant à lui de 179
signalements concernant six sites tous
gérer en israël pour ce qu'il qualifie
d' escroquerie et de campagnes de
marketing trompeuses dans des échanges
qu'on a pu consulter des sites menace
également d'autres immigrants potentiels
et les presses de compléter leurs
dossiers faute de retour sous 48 heures
je serai contraint d'effectuer un
rapport concernant votre manque de
sérieux et vous ne pourrez plus
appliqués pour immigrer pendant deux ans
dit par exemple its canada times canada
visa service parle de son côté d'un
mystérieux projet de loi trump qui
affecterait les francophones des menaces
pourtant sans fondement
quelqu'un qui est en cours ou en train
d'initier un processus d'immigration
quelqu'un qui est en train de voir ces
dossiers où ces demandes être évalué
quelqu'un qui n'est pas encore subi de
demande ne peut absolument pas faire
l'objet d'une interdiction de la
cordillère cessé de mettre des menaces
ou d'alléguer des choses qui ont pas de
lien de dire que les francophones seront
ne seront pas prioriser ces faux
également
deux entreprises israéliennes callisto
les mémos globales sont derrière ces
sites qui sont connus des autorités
canadiennes
calisto n'a pas répondu à nos appels et
même au global a de son côté reconnu un
pourcentage raisonnable de transactions
litigieuses mais aussi des annulations
et des remboursements pour anne tanguy
le rêve canadien a finalement pris fin
lorsqu'elle a fait elle même les
démarches pour venir au canada mais elle
a constaté alors qu'elle ne
correspondait pas au profil d'immigrants
recherché ils m'ont vraiment fait
miroiter du ray pendant tous ces jours
la ccir aux massues et radio canada
montréal